foreign
[Music]
that's gonna be the whole show this week
hello uh everybody fans and foes alike
this is Lifeline your favorite show the
most popular show in America on TV or
the internet as you can see I'm here
alone
there's no one in the chair next to me
you might have noticed Chris my brother
Chris is not here uh and there's a
reason for that am I allowed to say the
reason yeah yeah uh he is at the
hospital having
another baby actually Kristen is the one
having the baby Chris is there
spectating uh but yeah at the hospital
couldn't be here this week there are
more important things Believe It or Not
than Lifeline but this is episode
53 where did the time go wow we're doing
this just over a year damn
uh Chris uh despite everything that's
going on with him in his life is
currently on tour go to christalia.com
to get tickets he may be coming to your
city I'm not going to list the cities
though because I hate when he does that
uh if you have a question for us on the
show click the link in the description
below or go to watch lifeline.com and if
you want a one-on-one session
advice session with yours truly baby
baby pimpin pimpin that's me matalia at
matalia.com
uh book your sessions now and also this
is not the new but we got the new new
merchando
merchandasis merchion
decimos at the store and it's [__]
Pimpin pimp and that purple one is just
so good I wear all the time uh but I
already wore it on episode so I can't do
it now so Chris is having a second kid
and that I was telling him this this is
I I love cow so much obviously but
I like already have a soft spot for his
unborn or who knows maybe now born uh
son because I was the second born and
I've been thinking about like what it
means to be a second born as this whole
thing has been going on and uh it's so
so different you have things easier
because your parents have been around
the block
um
you get away with [__] murder but
also at least in my case the older
brother by way of the fact that he can
just adjust the fact that he can speak
there's this Dynamic that gets
established that he's the one that is
louder and sort of more advanced and
that set me and Chris on the path of
him always being the one that just just
would never shut the [__] [__] up
and I kind of took a backseat and laid
back comfortably and chilled and would
let him get into trouble but there's all
these like different dynamics that I'm
really curious to see
um with his kids especially what Cal's
gonna be like
with a little bro
I can't wait to see that uh my brother
spent and I can say this because he's
not here he spent a large portion of my
infant dumb I guess
pushing me into like doorways like
there's all these old home videos of
like we would be running into one room
and then he was faster obviously so he
would like pass me and in passing me he
would just like [__] elbow me into
the door
which was cool there's one on Christmas
morning there's one video of us on
Christmas morning I was a little bit
older so I was my head was at the height
of the doorknob
and he just
bulldozes me in the doorway so rude and
[__] does it like it's almost like so
fluid it looks graceful and maybe like
he didn't mean to but he definitely
meant to and he elbows me directly in
the door and I'm so happy and smiley and
I just go and my head slams right into
it and I don't but dude the best part is
I don't miss a beat usually I would stop
and [__] cry
but it was Christmas
and all our [__] presents were there
so nothing was going to stop me is this
on video that's on video that is
actually on video we should get that and
make Chris see it do you think that bill
has digitized like you know what I know
he has in fact that's why I've seen that
he digitized so much [__] uh
uh deeper for Chris but uh at his first
marriage
oh yeah there was like all this [__]
with the videos of them as kids and it's
deeper uh
City brief even though he's not here
um yeah so he did that
and I now can tell the world that he
ruined my life that's how he he ruined
my life by doing that and I'll never
forgive him and yeah hope you're doing
well Chris I'm sure everything's going
great can't wait to see you again can't
wait to meet the second born uh
uh let's just oh and also apologies for
last week I wasn't here I had kovid
which was [__] cool dude how about
when you know
uh this is my first time I had covet
when you know who gave it to you
you like wanna [__] kill them dude
even though that's not true of like the
flu or a cold you don't that's never
been a part of my life if I know who got
me sick I'm never like furious with them
but with covet now there's been this
like crazy three-year shaming of like if
you spread it anywhere and I've picked
up on that dude I spent the whole
[__] time so Furious
at the guy who got me sick [__]
Julian
calling you out dude did you know that
no yeah dude he [__] me Julian you
[__] me dude and you're lucky I don't
tell people your last name because
they'd be coming after you
on my behalf what's up are you actually
mad at Julian like how do you know how
do you know it was Julian so the way it
worked I because he I was in a room with
him
for two hours
and then the next morning first thing he
calls me and says I wasn't obviously
positive but I woke up feeling bad and I
have covered then two days later I have
kovid so that's how that worked but the
way it worked was while I had covid I
was I wanted to [__] kill him but
then when I got better
that immediately went away I I couldn't
hang on at all anymore to the fact that
I wanted to break his neck and bury him
six feet deep somewhere where nobody
could ever find him
um but yeah so I'm back and I'm stronger
than ever I think do I still sound like
a little nasally it's a tiny bit a
little bit right yeah
well
what are you gonna do all right
um I survived kovid
okay let's do it videos sure
oh hey guys sorry I am not there I can't
be there uh because
uh Kristen and I are in the hospital and
she's having our baby I already ruined
it for you guys uh I hope you're doing
well
yeah I hope I'm doing well honestly at
this point because I'm doing the video
here uh before that and um
and I just hope I'm doing well I hope
I'm doing well so when you watch us on
the podcast I hope I'm doing well
it's hard for men honestly uh the the pr
the labor because Matt I have to sleep
in a lazy boy and um she gets like a
really great bed
and they cater to her every need
and I I don't you know I don't get that
I just get a lazy boy and they go they
go
excuse me sir when I'm in the way so
anyway Matt I hope you're holding it
down like I I guess I know you are oh I
guess
so worried about me soon
so uh yeah yeah I don't need advice
thanks yeah you need the advice yeah
dude
well well well there he was uh he's
still doing well we've been in touch a
bit
um I don't want to blow anything up but
I don't want to ruin any [__]
surprises he might have so I'm not gonna
say much of anything about it but uh
from what I've been hearing so far so
good uh how to get a lazy boy he doesn't
have a [__] lazy boy does he
what is a lazy boy an easy chair she's a
lazy guy like a little boy that's just
super super iconic
um
wow damn that seems like Primo [__] to
get a lazy boy usually just have like
really uncomfortable Furniture in
hospitals
oh oh yeah okay never mind yeah okay
that makes sense
yeah
cool like Grandpa chairs that's what
they are
all right now I know what a lazy boy is
all right let's get into some real
advices though why don't we do it okay
oh wow I have a quick question
um
I have a friend
who is really funny and really awesome I
love her so much but uh she hates my
husband and my husband doesn't really
like her either so
every time like I call her
and stuff she's like oh have you left
them yet and I'm like wow okay
I don't like that I don't like that but
um
he doesn't like her either you know they
just kind of hate each other and I
really love having this friend but also
like sometimes it feels like I have to
choose between like her friendship and
my spouse and I don't like that so I
guess my question is like do you remain
friends with a person like that or do
you just put your spouse first because
that's what you're supposed to do
um but I want her in my life okay that's
all
oh wow the dip out damn she did that
good
um your lemon first of all I don't know
if you're aware of that but you're a
lemon and uh I think well first of all
look if you were gonna choose between
the two that's like
that's not even a thing you're obviously
gonna choose your spouse and I'm
assuming your friend knows that so
unless there's some kind of ultimatum
coming from one way or the other I don't
think anybody needs to make any decision
like it's a given you're gonna go with
your spouse that being said
it's not that nothing should change
because if your friend is doing that
every single time you talk to her
that is a shitty friend like unless
she's just joking and then she's just
annoying and you can ask her to stop
either way that's my point ask her just
be like hey I I don't know if you're
kidding even if you do know she's not
kidding or if she's even if you know the
answer
you could start with like I don't know
if you're kidding or if you're serious
but I know you don't really like him
that much but I'm also not ever gonna
leave him because you don't like him so
like maybe we can skip that part of the
conversation every time we talk maybe
you can not talk ever loving [__] about
my [__] husband
you know what I'm saying
um but yeah that's like uh
it's my
I feel like if she does it that often
maybe something's up like
she has like unexamined
feelings about him that are more than
just like I don't like him
because
that's so I'm trying to imagine it I'm
trying to imagine like say if a guy
friend of mine
Hado was married to a woman I really
really really didn't like I mean that's
that actually I that's happened it
doesn't
I mean I'm gonna say hey dude
I
every time I hang out with them or even
once probably I wouldn't even do this
hey dude your wife sucks when are you
gonna leave her like that is the rudest
even Beyond it being rude it just
doesn't even like it's not gonna it's
not gonna work because their spouse is
their most important person in their
life
so what your friends doing is just
through and through
top to bottom Turtles all the way down
being a huge female [__]
I would imagine doing that I can't think
of a scenario like unless he's like a
crazy cheater or something and she's
like you're but you're better off but
that's not I don't that wasn't even
remotely implied right so I don't think
it's that but yeah dude just dude just
tell your friend let your friend know
that you obviously clock it every time
she says it and that you think it's just
weird if you make her feel like you
think it's weird she's more likely to
stop than if you make her think it hurts
your feelings for some reason people
don't stop doing things when even for
their friends or family when they're
asked not to nicely because it hurts
their feelings you're more likely to get
her to stop by making her think you
think
what she's doing is like [__] weird
like and and and even like annoying but
not like don't it sucks that she's like
this because you'd rather just be
straightforward and say hey stop
but it seems like she might be the kind
of person that
needs a little extra push to shut the
[__] up about that stuff did they say
you're not even supposed to do that to
people you know when people break up
yeah and then you you have this tendency
while you're consoling them to say
things like ah that person sucked in
totally yeah
that doesn't help but well yeah you're
not supposed to because what if they get
back together and then and then you're
like there's another then everything's
[__] up yeah but also like it doesn't
help the person
I understand that in that situation
you're trying to be like oh it's
positive still like that wasn't good for
you but like at the same time that
person spent ostensibly like years of
their life with that person and that's
gonna be like what you just [__]
didn't tell me this whole time there's
just no there's no winning in that
scenario so the friend should know this
and the friend should stop asking for a
number of reasons
maybe that makes the friend a good
person in that through that lens you
know what I'm saying but not every time
of course not one and done if you have
to say something like if if it's dire
and you really really need your friend
to know
that you think
they should look at it and split it and
quit it is
you should just say you should you
should preface it like a long build up
and be like look I know this is not
really and I don't wanna I'm never gonna
say it again but I want you to know
that because I love you and and respect
you so much
as much as it pains me to say this is
what I think about your partner that's
not what this friend is doing at all
this friends according to the lemon
woman
every time they speak
imagine that dude you can't you can't be
friends with that person you can be
friends with the person you gotta let
them know
and not out of some like rule or respect
for your husband but because like that
person's being shitty as hell and
Friends shouldn't be shitty as hell
and that's just the bottom line of
friendship if the friend is shitty as
hell every time you talk to that friend
they shouldn't be your friend and Maybe
Kinda already are not your friend
and that's my story I wonder whether
husband doesn't like the friend yeah the
husband must be in a situation if the
husband knows that's the case
which well now he does I'm assuming he
does know that's [__] so awkward
also like help
the help smooth over the thing don't
like make it worse every time you bring
it up like that's your job as a friend
to make your friend's life go a little
easier a little smoother
[__] your friend
all right next
so happy so happy
hey what the [__]
what do you think about
um
for guys
frosted orgasms
[Laughter]
wow dude that might be my favorite
submission ever wow he was
I'm gonna play that having a prostate
orgasm when he did that
he's literally I bet he's actually
having a prostate orgasm let's watch it
again
just started just started
what do you think about it's rising the
intensities
frosted orgasm and he just came so hard
right at the end there when he says at
prostate orgasm uh what do I think
what do you think about for guys he says
um
well I think
it's not a very expansive thought on the
subject but
from and I have to say this I have to
preface it this way from what I
understand
they're like
okay so much pop yeah pop the top off
your the top of your skull and steam
comes out because it feels so [__]
good but
um I can't actually speak from
experience but like don't gross me out
but
I'm good like
I'm good without butts
button you know those [__] there's so
many guys that are like
I can't wait to uh
[__] in her butt yeah you know what I
mean yeah and you're just like
why
that's not better it's not better first
of all second of all it's not really
what sex is do you know what I mean you
prefer the vagina yeah and I don't
understand anybody who doesn't obviously
two gay men
these these people don't have a choice
but uh in
in male female relationships
and I I guess I should say unless like
the woman is really
into that specifically
I'm chances are I'm not gonna be Mr Butt
guy
and again nothing against butts I just
I'm myself I'm not Mr Butt guy that
being said if there's a way if you are
Mr Butt guy and if there's a way for you
to sort of capitalize on that or
maximize your Mr Butt guy Nature by
having
the prostate Tiki wiki while you're
going Jizzy Jizzy then definitely
definitely do that
or at least try
it doesn't seem like an exact um
an exact process though I feel like it's
kind of like
you got to have the right uh you got to
have the touch you got to have the
Finesse to make that go down right
um but yeah I don't know and I've only
I've only even seriously dated one woman
who's like
Little Miss butt stuff
and I again wasn't put off by it but it
it wasn't it didn't come natural to me
at all are you he's talking about I'm
expanding it to butt stuff okay okay I
know what he's talking about but there's
not much to say besides I feel great
about him if you feel great about him
you know what I'm saying I just don't
have any experience with them and from
but whenever I've heard
from me guy friends
is that it's quite
the Chisholm
experience you know it's like you see a
movie in a regular theater and you see a
movie in IMAX you have the IMAX
experience
when you have an orgasm it's like seeing
a movie regular in a theater but having
a prostate orgasm is like having an IMAX
jizm right and I'm so it's basically
the IMAX of chisholms
you should try it I think if you're on
the fence you should try it all right if
you have a partner who's like was is
willing to take you there you should try
it that's what that's what you should do
anybody any takers
I'm not saying he's not saying Anthony
have you that said yes dude you haven't
three ver three virgins eh all right
well maybe not for long
if you're the person to access my
prostate and give me an orgasm
let me know
you know how to reach me I think
actually please don't do that I'm not
serious uh
but yeah actually
um the one just and anecdotally uh that
one woman who I dated who was proper
into
butt situations
after we broke up my in my next
relationship my next serious
relationship
my girlfriend at that time
found all these [__] butt plugs
around my place
and every time I had to be like oh no no
that's not mine
and I in my going oh no no that's not
mine I've never felt more like a liar
even though I wasn't being a liar do you
know what I mean so by like the third
butt plug I was just like
I don't know what to say anymore you
know also why was that previous
girlfriend hiding butt plugs all over my
loft
is the real question
they were nice though they were like
Bejeweled you know
uh they one was a purple Crystal
did any of them have like tails on them
uh yeah actually one day dude the whole
the butt plug thing is like a whole
subculture dude
butt plugs
I don't really get it I don't know see
but I don't know butt stuff I know butt
plugs do something exciting as hell but
I don't
I'm I'm limited I'm a I'm a rookie I'm a
limited I'm a limited
butt guy
and I'm okay with it
I'm a limited butt guy and I'm okay with
it and if you have a problem with it you
can take a hike all right next
first off thank you guys for your
content we all love what you're doing
um I need moral guidance upon meeting a
significant others parents I think Chris
is new um they're coming up this weekend
to visit us at school or visit her but
the thing is I know I'm not in love with
this person I've been in love before and
I know this is just this is just not
there okay
um am I an [__] for being willing to
meet her parents knowing I'm not in love
with this girl
um I care about her and I like spending
time with her and she's really cool but
I don't know am I am I a dick
no I don't think you're a dick I mean
you
I let's see how to say this for no
you're not being a dick but you could
if it was distracting you like if you
felt morally as you put it uh
like it's a morally compromising thing
to do
maybe and I don't really recommend this
but if you want to you can talk to the
girl
and say it could be a good opportunity
for you to actually get your feelings
clear
across to her
as like with the you know through the
lens of under the auspice of like uh I'm
should I really meet your parents how
serious are we like it could be a good
reason to have that conversation if
you're looking to have it which I doubt
you're looking forward to having that
conversation but like at a certain point
if a relationship
is far enough along and you sense that
the person you're with likes you a lot
more than you're into them
it at a certain point is your
responsibility to
put that out somehow without being a
total [__] [__] it's hard to do
but it's it's definitely possible what
you don't want to do is string someone
along the entire time and then Blindside
them after you know you've wasted a lot
of their time
end your own time
sorry I still got some covered coughs
but
you're not a dick if you just are gonna
go hang out with a girl that you're kind
of seeing in her parents like that's
totally
a normal thing to do it's not written in
some manual that says you can only meet
someone's parents if you're serious
about them you know that's like
18th century chivalry
nonsense that's not that doesn't really
seem like a thing in 2023
but
um if you're having doubts about it then
maybe she's implied that it means
something
really like important to her in which
case again you should bring it up
and you shouldn't be a dick about it you
don't seem like a dick uh but you know
you you wanna
lay it on easy and bring it up as like
this sort of like practical thing you
know you want to have it be as like
height as as low tension as possible
um but yeah just actually I would
casually bring it up with her
dude if I was here's my thing though I
can't date someone unless
I know I could be with them
for the as long as the foreseeable
future is accessible in my mind
like I'm really not and never have been
interested in like dating like dating
isn't
dating in a sense of like yeah I wonder
if you did to that person what if you
did to that person like that that is
non-thing for me and always has been I
end up in Long relationships or I'm
single that's there's never like
Dayton play in the field [__] like that
that's confusing to me because why would
you be in a relationship if it didn't
have the potential to last
ostensibly forever
so it looked like this guy was in
college though and that is the agreed
upon time to [__] around in life
uh he had like a frat flag behind his
head uh so I'm a detective so it's all
good so I'm a pi
um but
yeah no I uh
if you're gonna why are you dating her
if you're not that into her
like forget meeting her parents why are
you dating her if everything's all good
and you both agree that this is how much
you're both invested in the relationship
and you've communicated that then
whatever but like
if you're not into her and you think she
likes you more than you like her
and her parents like why are you even
why are you even doing it at all you
know uh is my question
so may maybe you like her a little bit
more
then you realize and just don't want to
but now I'm psychoanalyzing a scarecrow
because what the [__] do I know I don't
have enough information to make that
claim
I'm just saying morally you are not in
the wrong if you go meet her parents
that being said why would you want to
meet her parents and if you don't like
her as much as she likes you that might
be the a good time or a good reason to
bring that up because that is a good
thing to have out in the open
so I just gave you really good advice
here's the thing if you don't take it
sometimes I don't think the advice I
give is like amazing sometimes I think
it's amazing the advice I just gave is
amazing and if you don't take it I'm
gonna hunt you down
and it won't be and it won't be uh it
won't be pretty for you okay
that's my advice right there
take it next
I am just seeking advice for
being a 23 year old trying to figure out
life
um I just got accepted into a flight
flight attendant training program
um that I am gonna go do but I've kind
of done a jumble of things ever since
I've graduated college and I've had a
hard time really finding what it is that
I want to do like I've literally been a
teacher I've been a recruiter I've been
a bartender now I'm going to go be a
flight attendant so kind of the Jack of
all trades here but I guess just what's
your advice um when you guys were in
your 20s and how you kind of figured out
life and anything would help thanks guys
okay this is good I think it's uh an
unhelpful
myth basically that we should all find
what we're passionate about and do that
because that assumes everyone has a
passion but that is not
fair or Justified or that that doesn't
mirror reality at all how many people do
we all know who who who whose job is is
is what their passion is in life like
that's rare it happens but that's not
common so this idea that we're all
supposed to find what we're passionate
about in life and do that yeah if you're
passionate about something then try to
do that that makes sense but if you're
like this nice young woman and feeling
this sort of like pressure
from the outside in these external
pressure to like find out what your find
what you're passionate about and do that
she's like desperately looking for the
thing that she's passionate about
and can't find it so she keeps trying
this trying that trying not trying that
that's fine I mean you're 23 you're
young do whatever you want for a long
time now you've got many years to figure
it out but
don't feel so much pressure to find a
thing that you're crazy passionate about
settle and I don't mean settle in life
like throw in the towel but settling for
something that you're good at that
provides you with the means to make a
living
is it's it's reward it will be rewarding
the rewards let's say are rewarding
enough to make that a worthwhile thing
to do in your life like
being a flight attendant it might not be
your passion but if you can get a good
position and you can make a ton of money
like that is a viable career because
then your success at it will lead to a
kind of happiness and your passions
like they should be for everybody for
most people your passions lie outside of
what you do for a living
like this is a misconception I think
people have all across the [__] world
passion
it look again if it ends up being that
you can pursue your passion while making
a living great but everybody feeling a
pressure to find what they're passionate
about before they settle into some
career good [__] luck and I'm not
being pessimistic I'm just saying this
is the [__] way it is find something
that you're good at that you can more
than tolerate and that will also pay you
and just do that and over time you will
build satisfaction and be proud of
yourself and you'll have money and thus
time to do things
that you're [__] passionate about
occupational passion
maybe one out of the 30 people I know
one out of every 30 people I know
is passionate at at work like that's
that's not even like a
think about it dude think about all the
people that you all know everyone
watching the show how many of them are
super passionate and fulfilled by their
job
that's not something that we should be
expecting in life it's great if it comes
along you're lucky as [__] if you get to
do it
but that is not even a realistic goal
for most people so don't feel like you
have to find something that you're
passionate about don't be crushed by
what the [__] [__] uh cliche
world is trying to force down your
throat it's not realistic
and you should certainly not feel bad
about not finding your passion
at least when it comes to the workplace
um
yeah also just to come back to this real
quick you're 20 she said she was 23
right
23 years old
I think so yeah that's so young
and I'm not saying like
I used to hate it when I was that age
and people would like tell me to slow
down or whatever because I wasn't where
I wanted to be in life in my career
whatever
but the reason everyone used to say that
to me is a good one
because like you don't get those years
back once you turn like in your mid-30s
from that point on life is just like
basically [__] same for everybody
where you are now it's full of
transition and mystery and potential and
doubt and excitement maybe passion but
like that
where you are now
to like maybe to your 30 that's like the
meat of life
just make sure you live it don't be
too distracted by
this like carrot that is constantly
dangled in front of your face about
finding your passion and making a living
at it it's just not it's a [__] lie
like a lot of other things we were told
as kids but that is a [__] harmful
lie because there's a bunch of people
out there thinking oh I hate my life I
hate my job I wish I had something I was
passionate about
because it's like so [__] thick The
Ether
you're supposed to find your passion and
make money at it
that's not a thing really so don't feel
bad if that's not your thing
uh vote for me that's my stump speech
uh yeah but 23 dude you're doing good
all those things she listed that she's
done in life that's already more than
I've done in life and I'm [__] 15
years older than you
so
congrats on that
point is
go easy on yourself take it be easy to
you be nice to you don't feel [__]
like you're failing because you haven't
found your way yet you're 23 oh my God
me at 23. you're good you're good you're
already thinking about all this [__]
you're good
all right who we got
Matt
what's up oh wow I need some advice for
my brother because he's four years older
than me I'm 23 so it makes him about 27
he's 23. he's been in college was in a
fraternity and he always claims that he
has never been hungover I've been hung
over plenty of times that [__] sucks
yeah and it just pisses me off every
time he says he and brings up that he's
never been hungover because I just
straight up don't believe it yeah so how
do I call him out on this [__]
something funny to say
um any advice would be greatly
appreciated keep up what you're doing
guys thank you
uh uh it's so weird if that actually
made him mad that his brother says that
you're saying it's weird that he gets
mad he said it pisses me off that he
says he's never been you know what I can
relate to that though because he's been
hungover you know right and I mean it's
possible that your brother is
misunderstands what a hangover is
like a hangover isn't
just one thing like I've had all
different kinds of hangovers I've had
splitting headaches I've been just
dragging my feet lethargic all day after
drinking for a night but prior like
there's a you get like sometimes get the
shakes and [__] you know uh
so I don't know if he's lying but he's
um he says 27 if he drinks ever then
he's been hungover I don't give a [__]
what anybody says so I kind of get
why it bothers him
uh but
dude what you should do here's what you
should do actually because you're never
gonna get him to like admit it
take him out one night
make up something to celebrate or maybe
his birthday's coming up maybe something
significant for him is coming up and be
like dude I love you you're my brother
let's go out
a night on the town just me and you
and everything's on me I got it I want
to celebrate our relationship we don't
spend enough time together just us let's
do it you go out and you [__]
get him so wasted and you do the thing
where it's like aha yeah oh my God oh my
God look over there and you dump your
drink out drink for a drink you're
matching him he doesn't know you've been
dumping yours
and then you seem like you're not drunk
so he wants to keep up he's like but
he's feeling super drunk and he's like
well what why isn't he he's not drunk I
must not be drunk because when we're
drunk we don't obviously think very
clearly and then
you you so you get him so drunk he's
like throwing up and he's all over the
place you put him in bed
then you sit by his bed in the morning
and wait for him to wake up
and the second he opens his eyes you get
on his bed and stand over him and point
in his face and yell
I knew you got hungover you [__]
you [__] I knew you got hungover see
and then
you're the winner
you know what I'm saying so manipulate
him well here's the thing I I I I
totally sympathize with the guy this the
guy whose video that was
because it's so frustrating when you
know someone has experienced something
and they're insistent that it's not true
and it's like it you don't know there's
no way to know if they're lying or if
they're like
uh
uh misunderstanding what a hangover like
on what the thing is you know what I
mean and I get being really really
frustrated at that that's like a
character flaw in me like I can relate
to that it shouldn't upset me that kind
of [__] but it does because it's like
dude you're hot you're you're preventing
us from bonding like you
have had a hangover so now let's talk
about it you know what I'm saying but
this guy's like nah I never had one so
you can't even Bond about it you know
uh uh I remember when I was in eighth
grade I was hanging out
with two of my friends who who happened
to go to Catholic school they uh they
went to it was John
yeah and Brian and they both went to the
Catholic School
uh so they were they weren't like goody
goody kids but like they were kind of
more repressed than we were at the
[__] Public School
and uh
I started talking about
uh how I masturbate this is an eighth
grade okay
and they both at the very beginning they
were both like you do what
and I was like what do you mean I do
what like what what are you asking and
they were like what are you saying you
do and I was like what do you mean like
I take out my dick and Jerk It Off
and they were like what like you're
weird dude like what are you talking
about and I was like I was like in
backwards land because I was like what
what
it's not weird it's not gross it's the
best feeling in the world and you guys
have never done it you know I was like
losing my [__] kinda and then slowly but
surely like [__] I was in like an
interrogation room you know and I was
the detective Detective
uh I got them both to admit that they do
it too and they had crazy stories they
were like yeah I do it in the shower
like this and I used to do it in my
parents [__] when they weren't around
and I was just like yes dude right I
[__] I cracked him
yes we all jerk off were you just doing
seven
yeah
Detective
I have a story you have a story yeah
okay let's do it it's it has to do with
masturbation but not do you ever have a
have you ever had
like the meaning of a word like messed
up for you for a while
because of circumstance I'll explain
yeah give me an example
I have a friend when I was young like
eight or nine
um
standing around on the playground some
one of my friends was telling a story
about uh something that they saw in the
news uh
like a bad some thing where
uh
some young woman was found uh
unconscious somewhere she was alive or
whatever and he was like yeah and guess
what
they found a pubic hair in her mouth
um and I was like whoa yeah and then he
said yeah masturbation is what he said
who's he my friend he said yeah
masturbation like he he said use the
wrong word he told this story and then
he said he he was saying yeah that's
what masturbation is and so I was like
whoa that's and so for
I don't know how long I thought
masturbation was this thing where you
knock someone out and put a pube in the
mouth
practice you know I just had this had
this supremely negative connotation with
masturbation I thought it had to do with
uh you know assault or right right worse
doing something to someone's mouth that
they didn't want yeah unwillingly and I
was like damn masturbation was pretty
bad that's upsetting that yeah that's
[__] being a kid is so bad it's so
confusing dude it sucks man like
especially if you're like an aware kid
and you're like you know you know
there's [__] you don't know oh I [__]
hated that feeling so much
I just always wanted to know what was
going on and being the youngest person
in my house this person in my grade
every year I was always like I always
felt like I was on the outside looking
in that way but uh
yeah just so you know that's not what
masturbation is though yeah
that's not what I was doing and that's
not what I got those kids in eighth
grade to admit to
uh knocking people out and putting pubic
hair in their mouth that wasn't our
thing no but like that just to get back
to that your brother does get hungover
and you're right to be annoyed that he
says he doesn't
and you know you you can do the thing
where you manipulate a hangover for him
which would be good
but you can also
if you are as
good as me with putting the pressure on
someone in an interrogation style
setting you can get him to admit it if
you're as
slippery slimy good as at that as I am
uh but not everybody can be
so yeah I recommend forcing the issue
okay who's next
what uh alternate universe me uh I have
a question
um for you guys
do you like let's say you're walking
down a sidewalk and then another dude is
coming the opposite direction toward you
do you guys ever find that kind of
stressful because I feel like it's some
it's sort of a thing where it's like you
can't be a little [__] and like get run
off run off the sidewalk this guy's got
problems or like yeah huge you know have
someone encroach on your space like as a
guy
um I I just feel like with with dudes
it's like this energy of like like kind
of get the [__] out of my way or like
you kind of have to hold your own it's
like I'm not gonna scoot over for your
[__] ass
do you guys ever feel that all right
peace bro you
[Music]
sincerely need help
like
what the [__] dude like how in your own
[__] like what was this guy's childhood
like you know what I mean just like the
most bullied kid of all time
no one's out there trying to [__]
size you up no one's out there trying to
gauge whether they can kick your ass or
not I wouldn't even go so far to say is
that no one's out there paying attention
to your path on the sidewalk what you're
doing is paying way too much attention
to this I don't know how you got into
your head that it's some kind of like
naturally occurring Showdown when you're
going one way and another man is coming
at you and passing you by like that's
just that's normal life on streets and
sidewalks
and other places I don't think you need
to
stress out I mean every once in a while
there will be a guy who has that energy
who is like
you don't want to be
in an alley with alone you know what I
mean it's like that I get if you're
sizing him up and like trying to make
sure you're safe take the wide route
when they act [__] crazy but like
just like a guy walking by me I've that
you gotta you gotta ease up dude you got
to go easy on yourself because no one's
thinking about fighting in that
situation uh
uh what I will add to that is
that video is possibly the most uh
deeper submission we've had because
that sounds so stressful dude this guy's
walking around thinking about everybody
wants to kick his ass he's got to be all
puffed out and not be a [__] and go
around but like dude you're thinking
about this too much everything's fine
the guy whoever that guy is is not
thinking the same things you are he
doesn't want to fight you he doesn't
want to [__] make you think he's
stronger than you he doesn't care about
you at all
uh
uh so yeah I think have I had versions
of that experience yes but only when the
guy is acting in a very obviously
potentially uh violent or whatever kind
of way like if I don't if I don't size
people up as a threat then I generally
don't pay attention to them if they're
strangers
uh but yeah I think it's deeper
I think you need serious help I think
that uh uh just here's the other here's
the real thing though
if you want to talk about switch
that's what it is that's like a really
good version of like you're
so in your head about like other guys
and like what they think about you in in
like a physical
threat sense like
steeper switch and you did it it's hard
to do both City Brand's a [__] but in
one Fell Swoop this guy comes in and
takes this City versus a [__] title
belt so that's impressive in a way uh
but yeah dude relax no one cares about
you in a good way no one's trying to do
anything bad to you and you don't need
to worry about guys walking past you uh
you need to worry about other things
that are real and really affect your
life
um but not that you know
we got one more all right yeah let's do
it
my name is Eric I'm from Salt Lake City
I was seeking advice on how to cope
reconcile or just handle
uh sibling that's
benedicted to
a certain thing
um that's going through rehab and doing
better but obviously relationships have
been strained and how to
slowly step toward getting a better
relationship
um with that sibling that you watched
left so yeah hope you guys have some
good words and talk to you soon
wait I actually was listening but I'm a
little
he's saying how do you can you play it
again actually sure
my name's Eric I'm from Salt Lake City I
was seeking advice on how to cope
reconcile or just handle
uh sibling that's
benedicted to
a certain thing
um that's going through rehab and being
doing better but obviously relationships
have been strained and how to
slowly step toward giving a better
relationship
um with that sibling that you want
love so just supporting hope you guys
have some good words
yeah I think that you want to make clear
that you know I think it's good with
with anything recovery whether it's
addiction or just even something like
major surgery any kind of thing like
that where like
people take stock of their life and they
look at it and they are in a
particularly reflective place which I
think is what one is certainly a place
that you know people that are recently
sober find themselves in I think it's
good to talk to people like that while
their mind is sort of
receptive to it to sort of be very open
and honest about
where you're at in terms of
what you foresee as a potential
relationship working between you and in
your case your sibling
I think that
more or less I would recommend
obviously in a different
way but to basically say what you're
saying on that video that you submitted
which is like
obviously there's like some kind of
contentiousness in our past but you know
this seems like a great opportunity for
like a new start and I would love to
re-establish our relationship in a way
that is healthy for both of us and I'm
you know really proud of you for finding
sobriety I know that can't be easy in
fact I know it's extremely hard
um but I want you to know that like I'm
not only here for you if you need me but
like
you know you're my whatever brother or
sister and as my brother or sister
whatever uh
you're extremely important to me and I
would love to be able to have a
relationship with you
that is not
like it has been between us in the past
the past is past water under the bridge
in as much as it possibly can be
now we start over and how can we have a
positive relationship
you want to frame it as full of
possibility too like you really want it
to be forward-looking and not
even so much an examination of where you
guys are at now but certainly not where
you were at before everything is
forward-looking and if you frame it that
way
forward-looking and sort of hopeful
about that future
uh I think that is the best way to like
start
piecing together piecing a relationship
back together again
because that shit's hard dude like
people even if you forgive
and forget there's still that like
lingering emotional
[__] that is really really hard to fully
shed uh
especially with family it's just those
ties run so deep and it's really easy to
develop some legit steeper [__] with
family uh
uh if you're not careful too years go by
and suddenly it's like oh do I even know
that person
uh but yeah that's tough but what I
definitely also know is that your
sibling will appreciate you doing this
again they're
if they've just gotten sober and they
got like you know they're coming out of
it back into the world like a re-entry
so to speak I think they can use all the
very like
clearly supportive people in their life
uh they could use being told that as
much as you're willing to say it uh
the The Sibling that you're
talking about the one who's newly silver
poly feels a lot of things like shame
and many negative things about him or
herself and your job your job can be to
help them not see things negatively
moving forward you know uh I'm sure
whoever you know typically when
there's a fractured relationship and one
of the people had an issue with either
drugs or alcohol
uh it's probably going to be that person
who was the source of the problems in
the relationship that's not to say you
were perfect I'm sure you were not
because you're human but uh
your sibling what I'm saying is your
sibling's probably dealing with more
guilt and shame and embarrassment
whatever than you are so be cognizant of
that but you don't need to like really
have kid gloves just be hopeful and
forward-looking like that's a lot for
someone who's down in the dumps and it
can mean a lot uh
to tell someone how much you mean to
them how much they mean to you when
they're in such a raw sensitive place I
mean I don't know if
I'm sure many of you have but to to be
around someone who is newly sober with
anything whether it's drugs alcohol
personal [__] uh
gambling it's like the people are really
really raw afterwards and I think they
can use the most like direct honest
care that you have to give
um
but yeah it's just tough man
I wish you luck that shit's never easy
but know that it's even harder for the
your sibling so uh
I I think it would be wise to open that
dialogue have you open that dialogue and
take it from there
um yeah when's this one coming out this
episode April 16th hey cool uh Happy
April 16th everybody uh if you want
those tickets to see my brother he is
still on tour now
uh get uh tickets at christalia.com and
if you have a question for next week
we'll both be here and if you have a
question for us uh click the link in the
description below
or go to watch lifeline.com also
subscribe to this channel subscribe
subscribe like And subscribe like And
subscribe like And subscribe
um or if you want a one-on-one session
with me Matt Delia uh
uh go to matalia.com and book one I dare
you I [__] dare you and the new new
the new new merch
is in stock and it is [__] pimpin
pimpin you get it at lifelinemerch.com
congratulations Chris you're not here
but congratulations anyway on your
lovely and growing family who knows
maybe it's already one person bigger
right now
uh thank you
to my loved ones Chris and Anthony for
producing such a lovely show and making
me look so beautiful every single week
even though that's mostly my work and
um all right that's it that's it
I love you thank you bye
hello hello hello
[Music]